my caddy wants to bring the trophy
so i'm like oh man you gotta look after
this thing all night so they wouldn't
actually let us up top we were going for
dinner they wouldn't let it in they're
like only the big trophies like the
stanley cup
so
i like i like all right whatever so we
put it in um
the little hostess stand there's a
drawer at the bottom and we put the us
open trophy up there went up had dinner
we come back down no one's in there so
we're like oh man is this thing gone
what is it so we get it anyways late
night about 4 am my cat is rolling in
him and his buddy are swinging it down
this lady taps on on the shoulder she's
like i think he dropped this it was the
top of the us open trophy
the lady was a little crooked or
whatever it was a little bent but um we
had a good time with it and then he goes
up to his room
he's got it he sets it down he's
stumbling for his uh room key puts it in
the door leaves it outside all night we
didn't woke up and painted because we
didn't know where it was
listen charles you were you were giving
a warning to brooks about vegas but i
think vegas is taking care of brooke's
capcom more than baby anyone else i